people shouldn't get excessively
enthusiastic but I think generally they
should be a little bit more optimistic I
think the main trend of 2014 is going to
be more of the slow painful same of what
it was in 2013 one big theme is the
question of the United States and what
sort of role America is going to play
internationally I hope the United States
has our big moment in 2014 that we are
viewed as being strong and firm and
credible 2014 will continue to be a very
positive year for the market I think
even more so for the economy I think in
our industry the big story is going to
be what does the individual investor do
do they embrace equities after this kind
of market run do they continue to hold
their fixed income investors are going
to be maintaining their current posture
which is optimism with a good dollop of
caution we think energy on a global
basis is going to be very interesting
for us like certain parts of technology
we think that will continue to be to be
of interest and of course with the
uncertainty and healthcare that does
create some opportunities for us